[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking welcome to basic
fighter maneuvers
as briefed today's exercise is dog
fighting guns only no missiles
we do not go below the hard deck of 5
000 feet working as a team you have to
shoot me down or else or else what sir
or else i shoot back
if i shoot either one of you down you
both loose
this guy needs an ego check
[Music]
he put some skin in the game what do you
have in mind whoever gets shot down
first has to do 200 push-ups guys
that's a lot of push-ups well uh they
don't call it an exercise for nothing
sir you got yourself a deal gentlemen
bike's on let's turn and burn
fanboy you see him nothing on the radar
off ahead he must be somewhere behind us
we don't get food again
what do we have here yeah here i thought
we were special fellas this here's
bagman hang man whatever what the hell
kind of mission is this
[Music]
everyone here is the best there is who
the hell are they gonna get to teach us
captain pete maverick mitchell
let me be perfectly blunt you are not my
first choice you were here at the
request of admiral kazansky aka iceman
he seems to think that you have
something left to offer the navy
what that is i can't imagine
y'all due respect sir i'm not a teacher
just want to manage expectations
good morning aviators
this is your captain speaking
then we're off
here we go
in three
two
one
we're going into combat on a level no
living pilot's ever seen
not even him
you think up there you're dead believe
me
my dad believed in you
i'm not gonna make the same mistake
[Music]
someone's not coming back from this
[Music]
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you